le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
pendant notre enfance nous avons tous eu
droit à la même question qu'est-ce que
tu veux faire quand tu seras plus grand
pour les filles les réponses les plus
fréquentes sont maîtresses docteur ou
infirmières pour les garçons c'est
plutôt policier vétérinaire ou bien
pompier
ces métiers font rêver les enfants car
ce sont des métiers de conviction où le
bien et le soutien aux autres sont les
maîtres mots mais en grandissant le rêve
s'efface petit à petit l'ambition se
dégrade et le choix se porte souvent sur
un premier emploi qui nous donne un
salaire alors comment garder son rêve
d'enfant et en faire son métier on en
parle maintenant dans lien social
c'est dans le sud de l'île que vibrayan
en ce samedi la plupart des jeunes de
son âge profitent pour sortir avec des
amis allez à leur sport ou bien ne rien
faire du tout
Brian lui se prépare pour tout autre
chose
aujourd'hui il va faire quelque chose
qui le fait rêver depuis qu'il est tout
petit
Brian se rend assez le plus précisément
dans la caserne des pompiers car Brian
13 ans et jeune sapeur-pompier
c'est grâce à l'accompagnement d'un
éducateur que Brian a la chance de
pouvoir faire ce qu'il aime je veux
devenir propriétaire professionnel
depuis mon plus jeune âge car j'étais
passionné parce qu'il faisait et depuis
la 5ème je me suis renseignée sur le
groupe djsp comment devenir pompier et
j'ai passé avec qualifications j'ai
réussi maintenant je suis JASP je suis
très content ce qui me pousse à devenir
pompier c'est parce que il y a de
l'action déjà enfin il y a de l'action
genre on va sauver les gens quand il y a
des il y a des feux quand il y a des
feux de forêt quand il y a des accidents
dans les sur la route pas des problèmes
dans les appartements et puis il y a
aussi ce qui me passionne beaucoup c'est
les sauvetement Maritimes car ils font
des sorties en mer pour sauver le PSN et
chercher des cours disparu par exemple
mais quand il y a surtout les
entraînements qui est assez passionnants
car ils font de la plongée
et qui a l'air bien mais il y a aussi
les pompiers à la grecque qui est
passionnant car il faut des
interventions car en fait les pompiers
civils ils peuvent pas descendre un peu
de 30 mètres à ce moment-là c'est les
pompiers de la grimpe qui doivent
descendre et donc il y a ça aussi qui
est super bien ce qui me m'intéresse
pour venir ici tous les samedis c'est
les cours le sport les amis surtout les
coups parce que ça nous apprend des
choses qu'on ne savait pas il y a le
sport qui nous aide à nous développer il
y a les amis qui la connaissent soutenir
et ce que je voudrais faire plus de
temps c'est pompier professionnel et
c'est bien parce qu'ils vont souvent se
désinterventions la défaite forêts
d'appartements et s'il y a des accidents
de la route
et
je compte comment dire aller me former
dans les pompiers méditer à Paris ou à
Marseille
et une fois la retraite j'aimerais
revenir pour PC civil à la Réunion
comme Bryan certains jeunes savent assez
tôt le métier qu'ils aiment faire pour
eux la vie professionnelle sera
forcément plus agréable mais la majorité
des jeunes a du mal à savoir ce qu'il
souhaite faire comme métier et une fois
adulte il se retrouve à faire quelque
chose qu'il n'aime pas les performances
et les ambitions professionnelles sont
alors fortement diminuées
consciente de l'intérêt d'aider les
jeunes à choisir un métier qu'ils aiment
la présidente du conseil général Nassima
denda a mis en place le plan ambition
jeunesse ce groupement de dispositifs
propose des aides et des solutions en
faveur des jeunes
l'idée les jeunes Réunionnais à trouver
leur voie et de les accompagner le plus
loin possible jusqu'à leur indépendance
professionnelle
c'est aussi pourquoi le 10 a décidé de
renforcer le dispositif de jeunes
sapeurs-pompiers en procédant à des
recrutements supplémentaires pour
permettre à plus de jeunes comme Brian
d'être accompagné et soutenu par des
professionnels le métier de pompier
attire les jeunes et dans le cadre de
notre plan ambition jeunesse nous
voulons effectivement apporter plus de
solutions cette année pour que ces
jeunes soient formés pour des jeunes de
12 à 14 ans jeunes sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires il y en a 54 nouveaux qui
seront recrutés cette année avec un plan
qui va continuer pour devenir demain des
pompiers professionnels alors un beau un
bel engagement un beau service pour les
réunionnais et pour accompagner tous ces
jeunes nous allons aux Istres plus
d'animateurs pour les accompagner et
former ces jeunes je crois que la
sécurité à la Réunion et son avenir est
déjà bien assuré avec ces nouveaux
formés
grâce aux différents dispositifs du plan
ambition jeunesse l'avenir de la réunion
se prépare dès aujourd'hui en apportant
son soutien et un accompagnement
professionnel auprès des très jeunes
Réunionnais le département augmente les
chances d'avoir des adultes épanouis les
rendant performants dans leurs emplois
respectifs cette démarche a pour
finalité de rendre la réunion de demain
responsable économiquement performante
et socialement exemplaires le Conseil
Général de la Réunion vous a présenté
lien social le Conseil général aux côtés
des Réunionnais